beautiful yep while it'll be easy to
spend the rest of the day relaxing
on this beautiful beach there's work to
be done underwater
that snapper i just tasted is exactly
what i need for my big cook
and lendry local spear fisherman tony is
the man who's going to get me within
striking range
okay captain i'm going to follow you
which way we can dive right here in the
length of this rift
if the courtroom let us do that gotcha
over to you sir
[Music]
i'm a strong swimmer but as i'm diving
down
i'm literally being swept sideways
we have a problem with the current it's
pretty strong
very strong
tony explains that the fish that
normally swim above the reef
are taking shelter from the relentless
current
he dives deep down to check out some
small caves where the fish
find protection i'm not joining him
because we're free diving
with no supplemental oxygen if i get
trapped in one of those caves
it would be game over
[Music]
king crab is a great catch but i still
have my heart set
on that amazing snapper
he's here he's here so we're gonna find
him let's see what happens
good luck so we came up with a plan
tony goes down into the cave flushes
them out
and it's like a teamwork i'm sat on top
of them and i dive and take them out
sorry that's on here there's a big
snapper here over there okay
finger
i started seeing these fish scupper
underneath that cave
um i took my shot
and i got it
yes i got to that
yes nice one
that was a big one down there as well i
got one he got
two teamwork made the dream work and now
snap up is officially on my menu for the
big cook
[Music]
you